hey what is up guys i'm pbht here and
welcome to my setup tour for early 2018
I saw it I just updated my kit which is
always linked in the description below
but as you probably have noticed that's
a pretty small list of things it's
pretty minimal pretty clean and that's
the way I like it and so this setup for
me is obviously pretty video editing
focus like that's most of what goes on
here and so that explains most of what
you're about to see that's on the desk
that's around the desk because that's
what I do here but it's finally
different this was a Mac Pro dual
monitor setup for a little while a
couple of years went by and it didn't
really change that much but now that
it's actually different and I kind of
mentioned I might be doing this soon
this is the new setup so uh let's do it
so I guess the first thing I should talk
about is the desk itself so this is or
was a next desk err pro I say was
because the company that makes this
actually changes their name to x desc
so I'll link that below it is actually a
custom size of it it's bigger than the
normal air pro and it's a motorized desk
so there's four motors one in each leg
and you can lower it to a sitting height
or raise it up to a standing height
there's presets so I don't have to know
where it is it just kind of stops it's
pretty convenient so I spend a lot of
time here obviously this was one of the
first pieces of furniture in the entire
studio when I first started putting it
together it's obviously one of my
favorites I've owned a lot of desks in
my day and this one is really nice for
having a motor in each leg it goes up
and down pretty smoothly and pretty
quickly and quietly and it also came
with a glass top but I don't really use
that at all I just use a straight metal
it comes in white and you can choose the
leg colors I went with the black legs so
in fact the Apple watch is not very good
at telling when I'm standing up or not
like I stand up all the time but then
the ring will tell me to stand up while
I'm standing up anyway that glow back
there on the back that is a Philips hue
lightstrip attached to the back of the
desk you can get different versions of
this on Amazon for different prices but
I like the Philips he one because I
already had Philips you stuff and you
can obviously change the color with the
app but I mostly leave it white also on
the wall behind the desk a lot of people
have questions about what this is this
is they perfectly aligned a
acoustic foam and fiberglass panel array
this is also one of the first things in
the studio very proud of it so now to
get to the things on the desk it would
make sense to go left to right like we
usually do with these so that brings us
all the way over here on the left to the
studio monitor speaker behemoth the
Yamaha hs8 and these things are amazing
these are an absolute workhorse and it's
another thing I've had for a while since
way before there was a studio or
anything like that they are capable of
incredible things way beyond what I'll
ever need it's an 8 inch woofer and a 1
inch tweeter and they're internally
amplified and the whole idea of a studio
monitor obviously is to provide as
accurate and neutral reference audio as
possible these do that as well as any
I've ever heard and they're sitting on
these isolation pads basically foam and
fiberglass blocks from RLX you can get
fancier ones if you want but these do
the job just fine which is to prevent
the desk that it's on from vibrating or
rattle actually Yamaha also does make an
H s7 and I believe in HS 5 so much
smaller versions of this cuz this
cabinet is huge but I'll try to link
those below as a matter of fact I'll try
to link everything I name drop or talked
about in this video
replica that like button wish me luck so
right next to that that brings us to
this this is promised Pegasus r3 it's
storage like that's it's just storage
this is a Thunderbolt 3 external raid
array eight hard drives 10 terabytes
each so that makes 80 terabytes of fast
access raid storage it's all hard drives
but it's also super quiet just one fan
in the back I was actually using one of
these with the Mac Pro before but with
an adapter because it doesn't have
Thunderbolt 3 so now finally with iMac
pro I don't need an adapter and speeds
are pretty great but this is entirely
for archiving right now so previous
videos unseen footage all that safe and
sound so that brings us of course to vi
Mac Pro this is the one I've had since
before it came out this is the one I
made a video about it's the all-in-one
non upgradable workstation performance
machine from Apple and I got to say I'm
actually really liking it so now like I
ordered a fully maxed out 18 core
version she'd come in the next month or
two not that I don't trust Apple but I
don't really think that new Mac Pro is
gonna be coming anytime soon it might be
like a year of using iMac Pro at least
before that comes out so that's soon but
for now this is that 10 core is the
w I've got 128 gigs of RAM it's a 2
terabyte SSD on the 16 gig Vega GPU
review is happening pretty soon probably
a little after CES but yeah that this
thing is a monster and it's sitting on a
stand the 12 South high-rise pro it
happens to match of course the exact
space grey color of the iMac pro of
course they did that on purpose but it
does look great and more importantly it
brings the IMAX display up to eye level
for me and those little cover up here is
reversible it kind of slaps on with
magnets either way and I keep the card
readers under there so the read mag
reader and an SD card reader because I
don't feel like every using the SD card
reader on the back of the ims now onto
the right hand side is mostly just the
rest of the audio stuff so the
headphones of choice on a whoo audio
stand are sennheiser HD 800 painted by
color wear so if you guys know
headphones you already know what these
are known for which is their performance
their reputation is top-notch
and they sound amazing they're known
mostly for their flat sound signatures
so they sound pretty good listening in
music but these are actually amazing for
video editing as well they're open back
so soundstage is fantastic and they take
a lot of power to drive which we'll get
to in a second but when you finally get
them plugged in and up and working it
sounds like the vocal artist is actually
singing directly into your ear it's
amazing so then driving those is this
little guy the Apollo twin mark 2 duo
it's again Space Gray gotta love that so
this is the preamp that is taking
information from the computer and
turning it into the signal that the
speakers and the headphones will play
it's plugged into both it's extremely
clean so that's what you're paying for
here so you can turn the volume all the
way up to earth-shatteringly loud and
there is zero hiss no noise it's dead
silent so it's capable of again much
more than I use it for but of course I
keep it because I love this thing but
also like who doesn't love a huge volume
knob oh also the chair how could I
forget the chair I mentioned I do stand
a lot but when I get into the groove of
editing that's usually when I'm sitting
down the most so the chair of choice is
this Herman Miller embody again another
thing I've had for years this is
actually kind of popular already too and
let me tell you if you sit down a lot
you don't want to skimp on the chair
everyone in the studio has this now
because it's dope I like it a lot so
that's about all there is with that
though also that cable management though
come on - and then all the other
miscellaneous stuff that's actually on
my desk this is
Hasselblad x1d it isn't always there but
I tend to kind of keep it near me when I
can and this is my slightly
unconventional keyboard and mouse and
trackpad setup mouse on the right
Logitech MX master 2's Space Gray kind
of on this aluminum mouse pad and then I
also have the trackpad on the left so I
use a trackpad mostly for zooming and
scrolling especially between spaces in
Mac OS 10 or Mac OS I kind of have this
three panel setup going and I move
between them with the trackpad
but then for everything else I use the
mouse so I'm not lefty I just have like
a certain weird way of doing things
people always seem to think it's odd but
that's the way it is my smart phone of
choice is sometimes also on my desk
right now it's pixel to XL panda an
iPhone 10 and this is also the new white
1 + 5 t they actually just came out with
this little white version which I've
been using for a bit and I'm a huge fan
actually of the colored power button
again seriously hoping this becomes a
thing and also if you're interested in
it we're gonna be giving away some of
these on Instagram so stay tuned over
there for a post coming up and the
chance to win this phone now we got our
red mags over here on the right some of
the new business cards a microfiber
sometimes my water bottle makes its way
over there oh yeah that's pretty much it
unless I bring something else over here
that I'm testing or starting to use now
before we even get to this part of the
video I'm sure someone's already looked
up how much each of the things costs and
like made a spreadsheet out of it in the
comments but before you even think about
it that way not all this happens at once
obviously in one move like I said I've
had this desk for about six years now
I've had the speakers for about as long
this chair I've I've had versions of
this chair broke it got another one it's
it's kind of comes together with time
the peripherals you go into the computer
that evolves over time but bottom line
this is all for me to make it as
frictionless as possible for me to turn
footage into videos and so that's it's
it's what works for me I think there's
two ways to watch setup tour videos one
would be just you watch one and then you
go out and try to copy it exactly you
try to duplicate what you saw but number
two is you kind of look through it and
you gather inspiration from different
parts of it you get ideas about how to
modify your own setup and I think that's
the way I watch most set up to our
videos and I think that's what I hope
you get out of this
is ideas for maybe you do want to make
it cleaner or more minimal where you get
ideas from the way I set things up
that's that's what I hope you get out of
it in this glimpse into what I use to
make videos so that is it that is the
early 2018 iMac Pro mkbhd setup tour if
you have any ideas or if you have any
comments feel free to leave them down
below again I'll try to link everything
I talked about in the description but
that's pretty much it thanks for
watching
touch you guys the next one face
[Music]